- Welcome to the 32nd
Kuznets Memorial Lecture,
organized by Economic Growth Center.
I'm Rohini Pande,
the Director of the
Economic Growth Center,
and a professor in Economics Department.
I'd also like to thank those
who are joining us online.
I gather we have a record number of people
who've chosen to do so.
Today's talk is being
broadcast and also recorded.
We'll invite everyone's
participation in the Q&A,
but remind you that by
being present here today,
you consent to have your comments recorded
and posted publicly.
So the Kuznets Memorial Lecture
is an annual talk focusing
on issues in economic development,
which the Growth Center hosts
in honor of Simon Kuznets,
the Nobel Prize winning economist
who helped found the center in 1961.
Among Kuznets, many
achievements was coming up
with the original formulation
of gross domestic product or GDP,
which he presented in a report
to the US Congress in 1937.
GDP was soon widely used to
measure economic development,
but Kuznets himself called
his own measure into question.
As early as 1934, he cautioned
against a narrow focus
on GDP saying,
"The welfare of a nation
can scarcely be inferred
from a measurement of national income."
In 1962, he added,
"Distinctions must be kept
in mind between quantity
and quality of growth between
its costs and returns,
and between the short and long term."
Today, we're going to hear from Eliana
about ideas that illuminate
this complicated relationship,
between the quantity
and quality of growth.
Eliana's groundbreaking research has shown
that customs beliefs
and other social norms,
can disrupt the link between
wealth and wellbeing,
and increase in equality between groups,
even as countries get richer.
Her work highlights the fact
that we can't understand
economic development
without recognizing the role
of informal norm-based institutions,
family groups, immigrant communities,
traditional gender roles, and others.
Eliana is the professor of public policy
at Harvard Kennedy School.
She will also be the incoming president
of the Econometric Society in 2024,
a society that Yale has
many connections with.
In 2020, Eliana received
the Birgit Grodal Award,
which is awarded annually
by the European Economic Association,
to a woman who has made
significant contributions
to the economics profession.
Personally, I've always been a
huge admirer of Eliana's work
and how thoughtfully she has worked
to improve our profession.
I'm delighted that she has
agreed to spend this week with us
to anchor the Kuznets
Mini-Conference tomorrow,
which has brought many young
leading scholars to our campus,
and to deliver the 32nd Kuznets Lecture
on changing harmful norms.
Please join me in welcoming
Eliana La Ferrara.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Rohini.
And so this is an incredible honor for me,
so I'm grateful to you, to the EGC,
to the department for the
hospitality these days.
Also, the opportunity
to organize this mini-conference tomorrow,
was so welcome.
And you know, it allowed me to connect
with many of the young researchers
that I've interacted with
in my first life in Europe.
And so, you will see for those of you
who are around tomorrow,
that there's a lot of commonality
and a lot of bridges that I hope
we can continue creating between
development economists here
and in the European continent.
So, I'd like to start
motivating a bit the choice
of the topic for this lecture,
and why I think it's
important to talk about norms
if we care about development.
And as economists,
we always emphasize the key
role played by incentives.
And we tend to think that by
giving material incentives
through markets or through institutions,
we can affect individual behavior.
And so, changing the
structure of incentives,
is an underlying principle
for many of the interventions
we have including
anti-poverty interventions.
If you look at other social sciences,
and here, I mentioned
psychology, sociology,
but in general, the focus there
when they analyze behavior,
includes many other factors,
for example, identity or social influence.
And within these disciplines,
norm-based interventions
are a lot more common.
And in that case,
the understanding is that
you can change behavior
by shifting perception of what is normal,
what is expected in one's reference group.
So, there's no reason
why these two approaches
should be seen as distinct
or mutually exclusive, quite the opposite.
In my research, I've tried
to understand the extent
to which they can compliment
and reinforce each other.
So Rohini mentioned Kuznets,
and if you read the motivation
for his Nobel Prize,
we all associate his contributions
to growth, inequality.
But the motivation actually mentions,
his empirically founded
interpretation of growth,
which has led to a new and deepen insight
into the economic and social structure,
and the process of development.
So it is important, I think,
also in the context of
this lecture to underline
that the importance of social factors,
has been there since
the origin of our field
and our profession.
So I'm gonna give you a very
quick kind of definition
of norms borrowing on from the
work of Cristina Bicchieri,
who's one of the leading
researchers on social norms.
And Cristina defines norms
as shared behavioral rules
that prescribe or prescribe behaviors
within a large class of situations.
So, we can think of norms
as a form of grammar.
Grammar tells you how
you should arrange words,
sentences, what is
acceptable, what is not,
in the way you are of speaking or writing.
And norms instead of dictating
how words are formed and ordered,
dictates the behavior
that you are expected
to engage in particular situations.
Now, these behaviors are
basically interdependent.
And so the individual choice
to comply with the norm,
naturally depends on the expectations
of what other people will do.
And there's two types of expectations,
one empirical or positive, we might think,
which is what do you
expect other people to do
in a similar situation?
So. how common is it to
choose this behavior?
Would a sufficiently large fraction
of my reference group take this action?
The other is the normative expectation.
What should you do, okay?
What do other expect that you should do?
And in this case, the question becomes,
is there a sufficiently large
fraction in the community
that expects me to behave
in a certain way, okay?
And these norms can really
play wonderful functions
or can become obstacles and be bad norms.
So economists have studied the
benefits of norms in settings
where there are market imperfections,
where some markets are
absent, institutions are also,
you know, have limitations
when it comes to enforcement.
And there's a lot of work
done on, for example,
the potential for informal
insurance networks
and or informal credit
and norms that govern cooperative behavior
within this type of transactions,
which obviously, have the
potential of facilitating growth.
But today, we're gonna focus
on the dark side of norms,
and of norms that might cause behavior
in a way that's inefficient,
not conducive to growth.
So the same type of risk sharing
that can function very
well to isolate the poor
from income fluctuations,
can also generate excessive pressure
or excessive solidarity,
as has been documented.
Or there can be norms
that prescribe what
occupation you are expected
to engage in.
For example, if you are a
member of a certain cast.
We'll talk today about a norm
which has to do with gender.
And unfortunately, in the area of gender,
you know, there's only an embarrassment
in how many of these
detrimental works you can find.
Well, dowry, we know,
are payments associated with marriage
that impose very high costs often
in the order of a whole
year of income for a family.
There's child marriage,
I'll talk about female genital cutting.
Historically, there were norms
like food binding in China,
there are norms even to
this day, for example,
that restrict women's
mobility during menstruation.
All of these are norms that
for us are not so easy to come
to terms with because if we
measure the expected costs
and benefit in terms of productivity,
they don't seem to really play a role
that would justify their existence.
So, having acknowledged this,
the question is gonna be why
are these norms still there?
And if we want to facilitate
their disappearance,
what can we do as policymakers?
And what I want to do today is
to take you through two sets
of results, considerations,
analytical work that I've engaged in,
one that looks at the evolution of norms
without a specific intervention
on behalf of policymakers,
and tries to understand to what extent
we can expect these norms
to fade away on the role.
The second is a more hands-on approach
where you think about policy and you say,
"Is there a role for
information provision?
Can we think that there's
some misperception
that is keeping these norms alive?
What is the role played by
culture or by identity?"
And here I will report on some recent work
that I've done with
actually some of the people
who are here in the audience,
and that sheds light using experiments.
And in both cases,
I will use one of these
extremely harmful gender norms,
which is female genital cutting.
Although I think, at
least for the first part,
when we talk about evolution
and kind of the theoretical
analysis of these transitions,
I don't think there is anything
that is really necessarily specific of FGC
in what I will say, okay?
So, what is female genital cutting?
It is the practice of cutting
or removing part of the external
or internal female genitalia
for no medical reasons.
It's an initiation ritual that's performed
on girls between infancy and age 15.
Very often it's around
eight to 11 years old
that girls are cut,
and it's again, in most cases
performed not in a hospital.
So, there's some risk
associated with infection
and you know, all
traditional health practices.
It's actually a widespread norm.
There's 200 million girls
and women alive today
who have been cut in Africa,
Middle East and Asia.
And once you have been cut,
there can be serious health consequences,
both at the time of
cutting, as I mentioned,
but even later on, increased risk of STIs,
difficulty of giving birth to children.
So, here you see a map of
Africa with a gradient in color
that shows you the
prevalence of FGC among women
in the age range 15 to 49.
This is data from UNICEF.
And you see, there are
countries like Somalia
where basically the practice is universal,
even countries like Egypt,
have had extremely high
rates estimated at 91%.
The other country I'll talk
about today is Sierra Leone.
Well, I won't talk about it,
I will just quickly reference it,
that where the practice is at 90%,
but you can see how there's
a very high prevalence
of the practice across Africa.
So you know, the first question
that we can try and ask is
if we take a long-term view
of how this practice have evolved
and what's gonna happen in the future,
what do we have to say as economists.
And I think here,
it's helpful to understand
both modeling choices
that have been used and policy approaches
in the light of what's
been the common wisdom.
The common wisdom is that with
something negative like FGC,
you go in and you say,
"Don't do it, okay?"
So the models are,
you have a choice of choosing
the detrimental action
or the other action.
And very often, these prescriptions,
even when they translate
into law, are not respected.
So, dowry is actually illegal,
but you know, it's not disappearing.
And similarly for FGC,
many countries have
legislation against it.
Now, what I'll try to do in
this first part is to say,
suppose that the goal is
to get rid of these norms
in the long run.
What happens if instead of
adopting a zero-one perspective,
you consider a setting
where there are intermediate alternatives.
So something that is still bad
but a bit less bad than the extreme, okay?
And in the example of dowry,
you could say instead of outlawing dowry,
you could put a cap.
In the example of child marriage,
you could say, "Instead
of saying it's age 18,
let's decrease the minimum
age at marriage to say 16."
What would be the effect
of something like this?
And this is an interesting question
because of course, there
can be implications
that relate to human rights and values
on which I will be silent in this lecture,
but taking the kind of efficiency
perspective and saying,
"What is it that's gonna make it easier
to get rid of the norm in the end?"
There is a trade-off.
So on the positive side,
you can think that there are individuals
who if you face them
with the choice between
a trait and nothing,
are still not willing
to abandon the trait.
So they would stick with
the detrimental action.
But if you propose a trait
that is to some extent a substitute,
they might take that step,
and then you go one
period ahead and you say,
"Now, that you are at
this different trait,
maybe it's easier to take an extra step
and so on and so forth,
until you eventually get
rid of the normal together."
And this is what
we're gonna call stepping
stone convergence.
But on the negative side,
think again about having moved
from the extremely bad trait
to the intermediate one.
What's your incentive to
abandon that intermediate trait
at that point?
Precisely because it's less costly,
you might actually decide
to stay there forever, okay?
We say that that becomes
an absorbing state.
In that case, the presence
of the intermediate trait,
has not helped you,
quite the opposite, okay?
So, we came across these trade-off,
precisely when we were thinking
about policy work in Somalia
because as you will see
in Somalia with the Salim
and other cutters,
as you will see, there are different types
of female circumcision.
And in our dialogues with policy partners
who were holding this
very dichotomic view,
it's bad and all forms,
should be really actively discouraged.
We started thinking, you know,
would it make it easier for us to focus
on the most extreme as
opposed to the intermediate?
But then we also understood,
well, there are risks,
and we decided to try and
use some theory to guide us
in our understanding of these trade-offs.
So, what this paper does is
to think about social norms
in a setting where is interdependence,
but where more than two
actions are allowed.
We will study the transition dynamics
and we derive conditions under
which this type of stepping
stone convergence can occur.
And then we develop an
econometric approach
that allows us to test
whether this conditions hold
in the data.
So, we collected some data in Somalia,
and basically, try to
map the model to the data
to see what can we say about
what happened in the past
and about the future.
And although as I will
show the Somalia case,
we think, it's particularly interesting.
There's nothing in what I say,
especially, on the theoretical front
that really makes this study
of transition specific to FGC.
So, why FGC?
Then as an example,
if you look at the WHO definition,
there are different types
of increasing severity.
They're called type I, II and III.
And in Somalia, indeed there
are even different names
for these practices.
Types I and II, that are less
invasive are called Sunna,
and type III that's more
invasive, it's called Pharaonic.
And so going to the model,
I'm gonna sometimes use
the term Sunna or Pharaonic
to give you kind of a representation
of what these actions are,
but just think of this as a model
where there's a large population of agents
and they can choose between three actions,
low, medium, and high, okay?
I'm gonna rank them in this
way when we think about Sunna
because what I have in
mind is the health costs
of these actions.
Of course, we can go back to this later.
If you think about either
a religious component
or a cultural component,
it's not obvious that
they would be ordered
in this direction.
But then again, as you will see,
you know, the argument for
stepping stone can only exist
where there is at least some benefit
in moving from the intermediate
stage to the other stage.
If the intermediate action, Sunna,
had both a kind of a health
benefit and a cultural benefit
and dominated the other two,
no stepping stone transition can occur.
So at any point, there's
a proportion of players
that choose a certain action.
And what's key, and this
is a standard formulation
in the analysis of norms,
is that your utility from
a given action will depend
on the vector, which includes,
you know, what fraction
of the population has
chosen the various options?
And while you do have an intrinsic utility
that's independent from
what everyone else is doing,
there is this social
utility which is decreasing
in the share of people
who choose action, J,
different from Us, okay?
And how is it decreasing?
Well, most models, Brock
and Dulo and others,
use these social penalty
factors where someone
who chooses J will
inflict a cost, S, on U,
when you choose I different from J.
So these S parameters are
assumed to be positive, okay?
They are zero for those
who choose your own action.
And so, this term is
what generates the desire
for conformity, okay?
And then there's an error term
that is assumed to be
extreme value distributed.
So, we're assuming the model, as I said,
we rank the utility and
we assume positive costs.
Different from what most
of the literature is doing,
we're not assuming symmetry.
So, we allow people who
choose I to punish those
who choose J in a different way
from how those who choose J
punish those who choose I,
which if you think again of
examples kind of make sense
because it's not obvious
that this punishment should be symmetric,
this complicates the analysis
because you can no longer
use potential games,
and proofs become a
little bit more complex.
But the key dynamics that
we identify are actually,
we are able to do it even
without the assumption of symmetry.
Time is continuous,
people receive revision
opportunities at random intervals.
And so, on average,
you expect to have one
revision opportunity,
per unit of time.
And agents because of these error term,
are gonna choose perturbed best responses.
So, most of the time
they play best response,
but there are some deviations.
And with the extreme
value distributed shocks,
it's a well-known result
that the probability of
shooting a certain action,
when the state is P is given
by this logic function.
And when the parameter beta is
the precision of the process.
So, when beta is zero, you're
basically choosing at random.
When beta tends to one, you're
choosing a best response.
And in general, although
the dynamics are complex,
a lot of the intuition
can be gained by looking
at the case with the large population,
and with you know, that
approximate best responses.
So, I'm gonna give you the
definition of stepping stone
and then the most important part
of the theoretical contribution,
is understanding the
conditions for stepping stone
and the transition dynamics.
So an action, M, which remember,
is the intermediate one,
is a stepping stone if
along every dynamic path
in the large population limit.
When you start from the norm,
that is the worst action,
you have that the fraction
of people choosing
that decreases over time.
The fraction choosing
the intermediate action,
first increases and then decreases.
And finally, the fraction
that choose the best "Action,"
increases until you
basically have the majority
of the population playing the high action.
And the dynamics have
this interesting feature
that there is an inflection point.
So, what's the inflection
point is when basically,
you are indifferent between
playing the intermediate
and the high utility action,
that's when finally the
process will make the jump
to the best equilibrium.
And in this case, we can say
that if M is a stepping stone,
that the transition occurs
in the following way.
First people start from the bad norm
and they deviate to the intermediate one.
This is what this smaller
step is allowing you to do.
At some point, there's gonna be enough
of a fraction of people that
are choosing the intermediate
that whoever deviates from then on,
can do the big jump directly, okay?
And that's a function of the fact
that by having reduced
the fraction of those
who are playing the very negative action,
the punishments are now decreased,
because the other group is now fragmented,
some play M, some play S.
And so you don't get
punished by a big fraction
that's playing the L action, okay?
And this is the expression
for this inflection point
which we did not with q Star.
So, if you think about the dynamics,
when you have a stepping stone,
what happens is that you're
starting from an equilibrium
where you know, most of the population,
is playing the L action.
I told you in Somalia,
98% of the women are cut.
You will see that until
more or less the mid '90s,
that was actually 98%
being cut with Pharaonic,
the worst form.
So, we were here, okay?
And then you see a transition happening,
towards the intermediate,
which is Sunna, okay?
Now, this is kind of a theoretical graph.
I'm not telling you that this
is what the data suggests,
but if in the case where
Sunna were stepping stone,
we would be seeing something
where the moment you approach q Star,
then the system moves
to the best equilibrium,
which is people actually
playing the uncut.
But if Sunna becomes absorbing,
at that point, you go here,
and then you get in the basin
of attraction of the M, norm,
and you're no longer reaching the uncut,
unless you were already starting
quite close to that, okay?
So, when is it that we can
expect this virtuous process
of convergence to occur?
The necessary and sufficient condition
in the best response model
are three inequalities.
So, the first inequality here
is the ratio of the difference
in social sanction when starting,
I'm gonna give you the Sunna example,
starting from Pharaonic,
you deviate one cut,
minus starting from Pharaonic,
you deviate to Sunna.
And this is the difference
in intrinsic utility.
So, having a relatively large
value of this ratio means
that the social cost
of switching from say,
worst action to the best one is too high,
relative to the gaining intrinsic utility
that you would get.
So that's why you're not
doing the big jump directly.
What are the other two conditions say?
These conditions are saying that instead,
if you compare the social sanctions
for going either from Pharaonic to Sunna
or from Sunna to uncut,
and you relate those to the
gains intrinsic utility,
this time the sanctions
are relatively low, okay?
So, that's why once you've
done the first step,
this is why you can do the first step.
And this is why once
you've done the first step,
you can then go to the
uncut equilibrium, okay?
So, you can rearrange this
and get that a necessary condition,
not sufficient, but necessary,
is the so-called reverse
triangle inequality,
which says that the sanction
for making the big step directly is
at least as large as the sum of the two.
And what's very intuitive
about this condition,
what's intuitive is that it tells you
that stepping stones
existence is related to a form
of convexity in sanctions, okay?
So, when you get punished more harshly
for deviating a lot from
the current state of things,
it's a good idea to split it into pieces,
because the sanctions for each
of the steps is relatively lower, okay?
So, this is all quite intuitive.
So, let's take the case of Somalia,
and let's try first of all
to see how these two forms
of female circumcision
have evolved over time.
So with Salim and other cutters,
we collected data in 141
communities across Somalia,
sampling over 4,000
individuals, men and women,
that took part in community meetings
for an experiment that
I will then describe.
And altogether, this
implies having information
on cutting for the female respondents
and for the daughters who are
approximately 6,500 daughters.
And what we know is,
what type of cutting they
have when they were cut,
then we know attitudes towards cutting
as well as beliefs
about community support.
And a first thing that was
quite interesting is that
if you look at the incidence
of these two types,
Pharaonic, Sunna, across sub-clans,
you see that they're
pretty much both present,
which means that one type
or the other is not an
ethnic marker, okay?
So, it's not about identifying
one sub-clan versus another.
You see that the share uncut
is in fact extremely low
in our data as well.
The other thing that's interesting,
if instead of sub-clans,
you calculate these rates by communities.
So, these are 141 bars.
You see that with the few exceptions
that are either entirely Sunna
or kind of entirely Pharaonic,
by and large, you see
prevalence of both forms
in each and every community.
And again, unfortunately,
not huge shares of uncut women
and girls anywhere, okay?
So descriptives, the age at
which girls are cut here
is around 8.5 or nine,
depending on the type,
and the decision to be
cut when we prompt them
and say, "Who makes this decision?"
And you can say, "More than one person."
You see, indeed in most cases,
the mother is held
responsible for that, okay?
In about one-third to 40% of
the case also, the father,
grandmothers seem to play a lower role.
Of course, this does not exclude the fact
that the mother might
internalize the preferences
of the father.
So you know, I'm not
making too much out of it,
but it's still something
that to some extent,
is implemented generation after generation
with some element of
decision also by women.
And I told you,
you know, there are
intrinsic utility payoffs
which can include many, many factors.
Here's the only one type of
factors that could go in there
and that's the health cost.
But these health costs we
find are quite informative,
because when you ask female respondents,
did you yourself experience complication?
You see that 63% almost
experienced complication
from Pharaonic, and only 11% from Sunna.
If you go to the next generation,
which is the daughters,
Pharaonic complications
are still extremely high
because this is really,
extremely invasive.
Those from Sunna go down to 3%.
And then we have the breakdown
into what type of complication.
And you can see a very similar
pattern where from Pharaonic,
you have all sorts of
negative health complications,
but with Sunna, it's quite low, okay?
And I want you to keep this in mind,
because you will see what conclusions
we reach about the stepping stone.
But intuitively, if you
are expecting people
to have incentives to abandon
the practice, for example,
because it's very costly
in terms of health,
this doesn't seem to be in
place from their understanding
or their experience, okay?
So, let's try and use
the model to shed light
on what the transition process looks like.
So, we need to map into the model,
we need approximations for
the stock and the flow, okay?
And what we are gonna do in the analysis
that I show you is to say,
remember the cutting age around nine.
I'm gonna say that if you are 10 or more,
and you have a certain trait,
you enter that stock, okay?
If you are 10 or more
and you are still uncut,
but when we prompt your parents, you say,
"Okay, your daughter is uncut,
what are you planning to do?"
And they have an option of say,
"You know, cut her with
this type of circumcision
or leave her uncut."
If they say that you're gonna be cut,
it's just a matter of time,
and they give the type of circumcision,
we actually attribute
that girl to the stock,
because in our model, you
get to choose once, okay?
So we are trying to map this to the model
and this also helps because at
that point, if you are uncut,
there's no single point in time
where we could pinpoint
that you would be uncut.
And this way, everybody it gets 10,
gets assigned to whatever
the final action will be.
But in the paper, we use other
forms of computing stocks
and flows and the those are similar.
So the stock is gonna be basically,
the cumulative proportions
for the cohorts we have.
And the flow is, in any year,
you know, how many girls are cut
with a certain type of cut, okay?
And we use three year moving average
to get rid of some of the noise.
And you know, these results are robust
to instead of 10 using
cut-offs of nine, 10 or 12.
So here is the evolution of the flow
from the early '70s, until when
we collected the data, okay?
So, the blue line is giving
you the flow of Pharaonic cuts.
So that means that the women
who were cut in these decades,
were pretty much always
cut Pharaonic, okay?
There's a slow increase
in the share Sunna,
until the early to mid '90s
where you see that suddenly
things start speeding up,
and then Sunna is now the
prevalent form of cutting, okay?
Everybody, pretty much most of the people
who get cut today, are cut with Sunna.
There are still some
girls cut with Pharaonic.
You see uncut is quite stable and low.
There's this little blip here,
but really almost unnoticeable.
So if you think about norms transition,
we find this to be a pretty striking graph
because it really shows one
or being displaced by another.
Of course, when you do the stocks
because there's the early flows contribute
to generating a cumulative
share of ironic that stays high,
of course, you know,
the crossing occurs a bit later,
but already these days the stock
of Sunna is now higher
than that of Pharaonic.
Okay, so how can we explain that blip?
So, if you think of the model,
what the model is saying
is that you're starting
from a bad place, PL,
that's where we were
with a lot of Pharaonic.
And then you are gonna
have some of these error
that you know generates
some people choosing Sunna.
As that share grows,
at some point, it reaches
a tilting point, okay?
So basically, the model
could endogenously,
generate the type of transition,
through the increasing
accumulation of Sunna.
If you read historical accounts
of what happened in Somalia,
it's also true that since the mid '80s,
human rights organization were very vocal,
especially, against
Pharaonic circumcision,
and eventually, religious leaders decided
to distant themselves from
Pharaonic and started emphasizes
that this was not a requirement of Islam.
So you can also think of this
as kind of reinforcing the
potential dynamics of the model Y
because you can think that the fact
that the Imams were now
endorsing Sunna relative
to Pharaonic is gonna reduce the sanctions
for going from Pharaonic to Sunna.
Also, you know, it's gonna
increase the benefits of Sunna
if you are a religious person.
And at the same time,
all of these campaigns against Pharaonic,
decrease the relative
utility of Pharaonic.
So, all of these can help
us look at what happened
in the past, make sense of it.
But of course, the
question we have now is,
given that everybody's cutting Sunna,
is this just the first stage
of a transition out of
FGC completely or not?
And here, ideally you would want
to have estimates of
those U and S parameters,
which are quite difficult to have,
and we try to have some
survey-based proxies,
which we include in the paper
to corroborate the other approach.
But today, I will not
show you those results.
But what's interesting is
that in the absence of
those parameters estimates,
you can still use some
of the properties implied
by the model and the
estimates of stocks and flows,
and that's enough to predict
what's gonna happen, okay?
So, I'm gonna show you three tests
that can be used in general,
not just for this FGC approach,
to understand if a certain
action can be a stepping stone.
So, the first comes from the
reverse triangle inequality.
Remember, we said that's
a necessary condition,
and with this logic
specification that we have,
you can express the log ratio of the flows
as a function of utility and
then the different stocks.
And basically, if you
write it for the flow
of uncut over Sunna, you find,
sorry this is a P that's missing,
you find that the coefficient
on the stock of Pharaonic,
is actually given by a positive constant
in the model multiplied by this, okay?
What is this expression?
It's basically the reverse
triangle inequality,
because remember, that
inequality was saying
that, "SLH needs to be at least
as large as the sum of these two."
So how can you test whether
the necessary condition
for stepping stone is met?
You can run a regression of
these log ratio of the flows
on the two stocks, PH and PL,
and just look at whether the coefficient
on PL is negative or not, okay?
And when you run that regression,
you actually find a positive,
not a negative coefficient,
which is a first way of saying,
"The necessary condition for
stepping stone does not hold
in the data."
So this is test number one, it's nice,
it does rely on the fact
that this specific functional form comes
from the logic formulation.
Second test is what we
call equal flow test.
This one does not rely
on the logic formulation.
What is an equal flow?
Remember, the inflection point that says
that, "At some point, you are gonna have
that the utility from
the two choices is equal
if you are on your path to a transition."
In particular, you can
derive the condition that
if at some point you
have a decreasing share
of say, Pharaonic, and
the stock of uncut is
at least as large as that of Sunna,
from that point on,
the system is predicted
to converge to uncut, okay?
So, this is what would be happening.
This is the equal flow,
means that at some point,
the flow of the two is equal,
and from that point, you
definitely go to uncut.
So, what have we done?
We have computed these sigmas,
flow into uncut and flow
into Sunna for every year
in our data.
And sorry, let me skip this.
And we have plotted the frequency
of how many times was this
ratio of sigma H to sigma N,
zero, 0.5, 0.1,
I mean approximated in bins.
Remember, if you say equal
flow and then you're off,
it means that the ratio
should be 0.5 or larger.
And you see that in our data,
this ratio is always to the left, okay?
So, it's a sufficient,
not a necessary condition,
but we haven't reached
that sufficient condition
in the data that we have so far.
So, that's a further
confirmation that test one
and test two don't tell us
that we are on our path out of Sunna.
The last test that we do is to
basically simulate the model.
So, what we're doing is
we are estimating the implied dynamics.
And again, given our model,
we don't need to estimate
all the parameters.
It's enough to estimate
these log odds ratios
as a function of the stocks.
And because you know, the flow sum at one,
basically, through this,
we can infer the mapping, sigma of P.
So, when you simulate the model,
this is the part for which we
actually have the data, okay?
This is what's been happening so far,
starting from Pharaonic, the
share of Pharaonic goes down,
the share of Sunna goes up.
You remember that uncut was
staying very close to zero.
This is what we're getting from
the model simulation, okay?
And this dotted part is the
extrapolation to future years,
and it's kind of unequivocally telling us
that we're gonna end up with
Sunna being absorbing, okay?
So that's the third piece of evidence.
It's not super uplifting as a conclusion.
The truth is that we still
have relatively few years
in which the flow into uncut
has been significant enough.
And it's possible that if
something change, so for example,
here we are simulating an exogenous shift
that increases by 5%,
how many people are
choosing uncut over Sunna?
Actually, with that kind size of a shift,
the simulation predicts
that you could get out.
So, I think there's some room for saying
that maybe with more years of data,
and if something happened that
kind of increased this talk
of uncut, aside from the
model dynamics per se,
we could get out of it, okay?
Now, I want to use,
so to sum up, if you
think of this framework,
you could try to facilitate the transition
by playing with those parameters
that govern the inequalities.
So you could try to have
sanctions being reduced
or you know, increase knowledge
about the relative benefits
or what kind of identity
payoffs people attached to this.
I want to just emphasize
that while I've discussed everything
in terms of this FGC example,
there are both historical and
contemporary examples of norms
where these intermediate action,
can actually be pretty meaningful.
One historical example
that my co-authors are
very fond of is dueling.
And in Europe, dueling
persisted for quite a long time,
and it persisted longer
in France than in England.
And one of the reasons is apparently
that they accepted a less
lethal form of weapon,
which is like the intermediate
action becoming absorbing
in a sense.
If we think more kind of recent
technological innovation,
let's think of smoking
and the introduction of
electronic cigarettes,
this could be a way to help smokers quit
or because the damage is
less with e-cigarettes than
with regular cigarettes,
it might actually lead people not
to quit smoking altogether.
So I'm told I have 10 minutes,
which doesn't leave me too much to talk
about policies to change FGC,
but I'll try to give
you a flavors at least.
So, if you now think of, let me take
where the head of policymaker,
be it the government and NGO,
who wants to help this
transition out of a harmful norm.
What can I do?
Well, one thing is that
maybe I don't trust people
to have all the information they need
to assess this intrinsic utility.
So, I could do information campaigns.
Maybe there's something that people attach
to these practices that defines
how they see themselves
and identity component.
And here you could think,
"Does the identity value really depend
on the harmful side of
the practice or not?"
And then there are potential explanations
that have more to do
with the part of the norm
that's about the expectation.
So for example, maybe people really think
that everybody's in favor of cutting,
but in private, they are not necessarily.
And that's a form of
pluralistic ignorance.
In that case, what you want to do is,
realign people's beliefs or
maybe everybody has the exact,
you know, rational beliefs
that they should have.
Simply nobody wants to move first, okay?
So, there's a simple coordination failure,
and in that case, can you
use coordination tools?
And some NGOs, for example,
Tostan have used these public
declarations when you talk
about FGC, you know,
working with villages to have
a critical mass of families
who pledge not to cut their daughters
or not to marry their
sons, to cut daughters.
So tomorrow, Lucia will present some work
that we've done in Sierra Leone
where FGC is actually part
of an initiation ritual
that's called bondo.
This is a group ceremony
that stretches over one month
in the sense that the girls
go together in the bush,
they are taught how to
become mothers, wives.
They really create a
mutual network of support.
And at the conclusion of this month,
the cutting ritual is done.
And we've worked with the local NGO
to test the effectiveness of
two potential interventions.
One is information about
the health costs of FGC,
and the other is actually to try
and discuss with
communities, the possibility
of using a ritual or choosing a ritual
that includes everything
else that's there,
but replaces the cutting
with an alternative sign.
So, preserving in some way,
the symbolic value of the practice.
And if you want to know what
happens, show up tomorrow.
Now, what I want to instead
maybe say a little bit more
about is another intervention
that we did with the
subset of the quarters
of the Somalia transitions paper.
And this is about
beliefs and coordination.
So here, we're gonna tackle this idea
that maybe people are
privately against FGC,
but you know, they misperceive
other people's support for it
or there is this coordination failure.
So, what we've done there is
to hold community meetings
where, sorry, we gather
people in a group of
about 30 participants in rural villages,
and they were given a secret ballots
where they could say yes or no,
if they wanted to abolish
Pharaonic circumcision.
So, there was no way to identify
who was voting in a certain way.
And once they cast their vote,
we incentivize everybody to guess
what the number of people
in support of abandoning
Pharaonic circumcision,
would've been, okay?
Then in some of the
communities, we end the meeting.
In these communities
what we will have is the
private support for the practice
and the beliefs about the
community level support.
In one group of communities,
we open the ballot box,
and we say, "Here is
how many actually voted
in favor of my abandoning."
So, this is the case
where you are correcting
if there are misperceptions,
you are realigning beliefs
with the actual preferences.
And then we thought, you know,
it's important to think that
aside from the beliefs part,
there might be this coordination problems.
So, we try to design the
lab in the field equivalent
of this public declarations.
In some communities,
the people who was running
the meeting drew a circle
on the floor and said,
"If you are in favor of
abolishing Pharaonic circumcision,
you can step into the circle."
So, this is gonna be our
coordination treatment.
And then there's a third
group of communities
where we first reveal the sharing support
and then we ask who wants
to step into the circle.
Okay, we have three
rounds of data collection
from 2018 to '21,
and there's data on
traditional circumcisors
that we also have and
I will not discuss now.
So first, I'll just show you this graph
which has evidence that there
is indeed a significant extent
of misperception, why?
Because here you have the share of people
who support the abandonment
of Pharaonic vote,
you know, from zero to 100%
of the meeting participants.
And the green dash line is the
actual vote, anonymous vote.
So, we have no reason
to think that they lied.
This is telling us that in the
vast majority of communities,
the share is greater than 60%
with a very large fraction
where it's almost close to 100%.
But the respondents prior about
how many are in favor of
abandoning is shifted to the left,
which means that they
actually expect less support,
than there is in practice, okay?
So this opens the possibility
for correcting these misperceived beliefs.
And similarly, if you
think about coordinator,
this is the same thing,
which is the guess about those who are
in favor of abandoning.
So, this is the belief,
and these are the number of people
who ended up entering the circle, okay?
So this exercise led more people to step
into the circle than what they expected
to be the public support for the practice.
And I'll skip this one and
just go quickly to the result
because I'm almost out of time.
So first of all, we go there,
this is endline data.
So, it's two years after the intervention,
and this is the share of girls
who've been Pharaonic cut, okay?
So you know, the meaning the
control group is quite low
because I already told you
that nowadays most people cut Sunna.
You could say, "Why did you
do the experiment on Pharaonic
and not on Sunna then?"
Because in our pilot,
we understood that the support
for Sunna was quite high.
So if you do one of these,
open the ballot experiments
and then you say,
"You know, 95% of the people
are supporting Sunna,"
you're not gonna have much of
a a decrease in cutting rates.
And at the same time, we
also did feel that given
how much more harmful these practice is,
even going from 4% to a lower
number was an important goal.
And in fact, we managed to
reduce it by 1.6% points.
Now, what we were not sure would happen
and happened or you know,
could have happened or not,
and instead happened was that
in this span of two years,
the rate of Sunna cuts actually went up,
and the share of girls who
was uncut went down, okay?
So, having seen that model
with the intermediate action,
this is not so surprising
because something
that can happen is that in fact,
you go away from Pharaonic,
you make the step to Sunna.
And now, that Sunna
becomes more appealing,
there might be some people who from uncut,
are induced to actually choose the Sunna.
So, this would not be a
very desirable outcome.
However, it's also true
that these two years
after the intervention,
is not giving you the steady state
because girls get cut in
a certain age interval.
So, if we want to know what
this does to parents preferences
and to parents' choices for
all the girls that they have,
including those who are
too young to be cut,
we should factor in the preferences
about uncut girls, okay?
So, in this table,
you have the old result probability
of being uncut goes down.
But then we look at
whether for those uncut,
the parents say that,
"They're planned to be cut in the future
or planned not to be cut, okay?"
And what's happening is that
this number masks a reduction
in those who are planned
to be cut in the future,
and an increase in those who
for the future are planned not
to be cut.
And indeed, if you look
at the age of cutting,
it goes down a little bit,
and sorry, I didn't say it before,
but everything we have
in terms of results,
is pretty much driven by the
misperceptions intervention.
It turns out that our coordination device,
didn't work as well.
And so, in fact, the age of
cutting went down a little bit,
which means that that increase in Sunna
that we saw is probably, you know,
some girls whose cut wasn't anticipated.
It was done a Sunna.
And then if we take the
long-term perspective and say,
now, let's take everybody,
and if you are Pharaonic
cut now or plan to be,
we give you a one.
Sunna cut or plan to be an uncut
and plan to stay uncut.
If you take all of this,
the endpoint seems to be
that there's actually
an increase in the share
that in the long-term is gonna be uncut.
Of course, with these plans,
we could say maybe it's cheap talk,
we don't know what the parents
are gonna do in the end.
So, the only thing we can do here is,
because we had the
midline and the endline,
we compared the plans that
they gave us at midline
with the action that
they declare it endline
in the age range in which
the girls are most at risk.
And we have 532 girls of which basically,
39 have been cut when the
parents at midline had said,
"She's gonna stay uncut, okay?"
So we have a 7% deviation from intentions,
which again, you know,
eventually, doesn't seem a
hugely important problem.
But it's also true that
this is all we have
in terms of the data.
So, I'll skip the
additional results and just,
I think just say that in the
context that we've studied,
pluralistic ignorance
seems to play a role.
And so in that case, simple intervention,
based on correcting
misplaced beliefs is viable.
The coordination exercise
seemed less effective and that,
you know, disregarding this role
of intermediate roles is
actually a limitation,
because we saw that in the short run,
at least, some of what
happens was an increase
of the intermediate form.
So, there's something that
I have completely left out
of this discussion and we
had a very interesting,
for me, conversation with
Rohini and Sam today,
which is actually the role of the law,
and of the institutions,
because all I've tried
to discuss is still informally enforced.
It's still a way
of having the kind of
the social norm aspect,
not sanctioned by an
authority, a legal authority.
I think, it's very important
to also pay attention
to how legal and institutional solutions
to norms change can be implemented
when they are successful,
were not, and also I think,
a longstanding question is
eventually you want people
to own these changes.
This means that their attitudes,
towards harmful norms need to change.
So, what comes first?
Will my attitudes change because
I see a different behavior
or is a different behavior
generated by attitudinal change?
And I haven't found a way
of solving this obvious
endogeneity problem,
but for me, given this type of questions,
it's an obvious important
future avenue for more work.
So, thank you for your patience
with me going slightly over time.
(audience applauding)
- [Rohini] I think we now have time
for questions, so (indistinct)
- [Man] Thank you.
Thank you very much,
Eliana, for visiting us.
- [Man] For visiting the center.
(all laughing)
- [Man] So, I wanted to
just connect the three parts
of your presentation.
I really like the experiment
you just described
in Sierra Leone, which is, you know,
beliefs about what other people,
my beliefs about--
- Somalia, Somalia.
- Oh sorry, that was Somalia, okay.
- Yeah, Sierra Leone is tomorrow.
- Okay, all right.
Okay, I like it even better.
- Yeah.
- So, that's about norms.
You know, my beliefs about
what other people think
I should be doing, right?
Now, but in the middle part,
when we were talking
about this aggregate data
and seeing movements from
Pharaonic to Sunna, right?
I mean, we have these standard problems
with those aggregate data that's just
about correlated none
of the rebels, right?
Like as you said,
it could just be religious
edict that matter.
So, all of that could just be signaling
that what we should be
focusing on is religious edicts
or changing the law or
something like that, right?
And that's why in the labor literature,
you know, how you define
or how Cristina Bicchieri,
you said, defined norms,
it sounded like a strategic
complementarity, right?
My decision to adopt depends
on what other people are doing.
And there, you know,
in the peer effects literature, in labor,
we know that we have to be very careful,
like the mass and Moretti
type approach on, right?
So, I just worry,
I mean, I like the beliefs part,
but I just worry that
if you're not careful
about how we use the word norms,
maybe we would be
misattributing the importance
of law changes to focusing
too much on norms.
- Yeah, so thank you.
And this helps me clarify something
which I hope I didn't use causal language,
when I was describing that middle part,
if I did, absolutely not intended.
But so the way I presented
the transition or the flow,
it's basically indistinguishable for us,
whether it was governed by the dynamics,
by the religious leaders action.
We are not making much out of that.
We're just saying, "This is a context
where the three actions make sense."
If you take historical data,
you see the switch, that's it.
What we're trying to use the model for is
to say with aggregate data,
what should you see as a precondition
for this now getting you
out of Sunna altogether.
And we are just showing
that we are not seeing that.
So, it's more like saying on the basis
of what the model predicts,
just the evolution of
those stocks and flows,
is not consistent with the
second step of the transition.
We're not saying that, you know,
if religious leaders intervene now,
Sunna would no longer be absorbing.
So, all of this is for us, I think,
a way of asking, can you use
this analytical framework
where there is interdependency
and where you are just
trying to understand,
am I in a situation where
there is a form of convexity
that would generate this pattern
of stocks and flows or not?
And purely descriptively,
you're saying this doesn't match it,
but we know that we cannot
attribute a cause and effect,
especially, to the first part of data,
because we know there
have been also evolutions
in the institutional framework
that we are not modeling.
Let me also say why we
decided not to take a path
where we start modeling incentives
of religious leaders and so on.
We're trying to see this
as really as applicable as possible
to many different types of norms.
And the moment we get more serious
and more realistic about the
Somali institutional setting,
we lose the ability to use the same model
for e-cigarettes, for example.
So this comes at a cost,
we know there are some interesting feature
of what happened there
that we're not capturing,
but I think, it's still instructive
to show that even with this
extremely stylized framework,
we are able to say something
about what comes next if the
parameters stay constant.
So, that's another big thing.
I don't know if that was the
next question by someone,
but of course, those
conditions and everything says
that the excess and the
use for the coming years
to which we extrapolate are
the ones for the past year.
Big assumption, okay.
Penny.
- [Penny] First, I think
this is super interesting.
I would love to see (indistinct)
So one type of policy intervention,
you didn't spend much time
on is strong paternalistic interventions.
And here, I'm thinking of smoking.
So in your model, this utility,
the cost of all this
practices is extremely high,
I don't think any woman
or any girl would claim
that they enjoyed the
practice as opposed to smoking
where most smokers actually love to smoke.
And so the cost there was low.
And yet I think somehow we managed,
at least in the US to
move from an equilibrium
where everyone smoked to one
where at least within the educated class,
most people don't smoke.
And the only explanation,
the only policy
intervention I can think of,
was very strong paternalism.
So, I'm wondering why you
haven't been more pushy
on that front.
- Okay.
- I think, so if you
think of this paternalism,
it is not obvious that the
appeal of the intermediate norm
at that point becomes so crucial.
You might as well try
and be paternalistic towards
the most desirable state.
So, we had this idea of thinking
about step-wise processes.
I also don't know in the smoking case,
I do agree there was an important role,
played by paternalism.
You know, I like to think about, you know,
things like television or, you know,
and in my view, what happened
with smoking was also
that it started being
considered less cool.
So, in terms of how young
people, for example,
choose whether to smoke or not,
I think, the image around
who is a smoker kind of
changed over the years.
And now, smokers disappeared from movies,
and now they're back.
And so I do think, and I'm not
able to quantify in any way,
you know, this is super,
not grounded in any serious
research that I've done.
And maybe there is that I can look at,
but to me, it was a combination
of a paternalistic interventions
having certain pictures
on the packs of cigarettes
and all of that,
but also, how society started portraying
and viewing smokers,
no longer so desirable.
And then I think nowadays,
strong lobbying to have it back
in some form of desirable practice.
But so, yeah, maybe I didn't think I had
so much to say about
paternalistic approaches,
which doesn't mean that
they're not important,
similar to the law and
the issue of institutions.
- So, yeah, to follow up on this question,
I will maybe frame it a bit differently,
but talking about not
non-paternalistic approach,
but top down, like for instance,
you have a powerful Imam
that changed his mind,
or you manage to negotiate
with Imam and said,
"Why don't you pretend
that we are doing this?
You know, we pay you this,
and then you tell everyone
else that we are not going
to do this anymore."
You know, I think, in West Africa,
particularly, in Benin, for instance,
I learned a lot of instances
where you are not, I mean,
like we want to stop,
let's say, physical punishment
for some misbehavior.
And the way to do it is,
you pretend that this is
what you are punishing
the person physically,
but then you don't.
You know, is as if there is,
it becomes just like a ritual,
so that you do it, but and
then you are not doing it
because you minimize, you know?
So in this context, for instance,
did you have to deal
with some local leaders
and try to leverage their influence
to rethink the whole practice
a little bit, you know?
Have you run into this?
- So it's an excellent point.
In the Somali context, we of
course had to get permission
to go in the communities,
hold the meetings.
There was no point of negotiation
or conflict of interest
because given that we
were not discussing Sunna,
but we were only talking about Pharaonic,
there is a full alignment and
there are parts of Somalia
where Imams have even issued
fat words against Pharaonic.
In Puntland, for example, in 2018.
so in that respect,
we were not in a position where we said,
"Let's try together to
get out of the practice
that you are actually
most associated with,
which is what the Sunna is."
We did collect the data on circumcisors
because we also wanted to
understand incentives of the ones
who practice it.
And you might think that
in addition to having the Imams
sanctioning different ways
of performing the ritual or abandoning it,
you would also need the
compliance by the circumcisors.
And so that part to us
is interesting to study.
I cannot speak for Celine,
but if I were to say, "What
do you think is gonna work?
Do you feel that everything
you've tried is, that's it?"
I wouldn't say so.
I would think that involving
the local leaders is,
probably, something that's
first order importance.
It's something that maybe
requires a lot more embeddedness
in the local context.
Somalia is a very difficult
context for us to work
in as outsiders.
And so, but I do agree with you
that it might be the most
promising strategy on paper.
In West Africa, it was a bit different
because we were very careful with Lucia
to try and avoid as much as possible,
this top-down approach.
Because in fact, you know,
the local understanding of bondo or FGC,
is a lot less negative
than what we portrayed,
and the interaction with
the communities were handled
by this NGO.
And this is, it's called
Amazonian Initiative Movement.
It's actually, for many years,
they've been acting off the ground.
And what they do is they try,
and because it's a secret society thing,
they try and say, "You choose the sign,
you choose what you want to do."
But they try and just
remove the association
of all the good things of
bondo with the cutting,
again, what could there be
in terms of institutional partnerships?
In that case, we think it's
slightly more complicated.
The government hasn't
shown a determination
to go against bondo in
Sierra Leone so far.
I would love to hear more about Benin
because that's one context
where we haven't worked.
Thank you.
- Okay, I also have a question.
So, talking a little bit about the law
and the institutional side things.
So in Somalia, you didn't
say if it was illegal
to start with.
- So I don't think it
is illegal, the Sunna.
- But the--
- So, the Pharaonic has
been banned with the--
- So then, the question is a
little bit on this top down
or this legal settings.
It's who are you punishing
or who is the law against?
Is it against the mother?
Is it against the doctor who's doing it,
and how can you institutionalize
and monitor that it happens?
- It's not easy at all because except,
I mean, the Sierra Leone is a case
where monitoring is super
easy because it's a group,
and you know, if you know
a bunch of girls are gone
for a month.
In many other settings, it's done at home.
It's a very private act.
The only case I'm familiar with,
I mentioned it today in our discussion,
is that of Burkina Faso.
Burkina also has a practice of FGC,
but it recent years,
its banned and the government has decided
to enforce the law.
So Lucia and I initially thought
about doing an intervention
in Burkina, and we started some
focus group and pilot work,
and it became clear to us
that people didn't want to talk about it.
They were extremely
reluctant to discuss FGC.
They said, "There's no
FGC in our communities."
And we later learned that
there had been trials
that had been brought to the rural area.
So instead of, so both the family
and the circumcisors were punished,
and instead of holding
them in the capital,
they were on purpose held in locations
where the population would become aware.
And this apparently,
at least in terms of
willingness to discuss it
or to report it, had an effect.
I don't know if it had an
effect on cutting rates,
but, and we haven't gone back to study
why they became serious about
enforcing how they did it.
We read about these trials,
but I do think that is, you know,
it's one instance where finding out
about it would probably
come from some monitoring
of the circumcisors and then
probably that's how they do it.
- Thanks for the really
interesting presentation.
In your model, one thing I
was interested in was the fact
that the reference group is
kind of exogenously given,
and I know this is outside the scope
of what you talked about,
but maybe if you had
some speculative thoughts
about what happens when
reference groups come
into contact with each other,
or are there cases where
some subgroup might decide
to split off and kind of divorce itself
from the broader reference
group to protect a norm?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
In fact, you know,
almost by definition, if you
wanted to split the population
into, now my reference
group are the people
who are choosing my action, I pay no cost.
You know, I'm always free to deviate.
So, I think the problem is
interesting to the extent
that you cannot fully
redefine the reference group
in a way to align it to
your own preferences.
Now, is there a feasible way
from an analytical perspective
to study an intermediate version
that's not the full population
health constant as I did,
not the extreme in which my
reference group is always
whoever thinks like me,
but there's a partition that's different.
I'll be honest, I haven't
seen anything like this,
at least in the social
norms literature, of course,
people working on
coalitions might have tools
that come in handy.
And I don't know whether any
of what we've done would
generalize to that setting.
In principle, it should make
it easier to transition on
because you're always
decreasing the punishment
if you strategically redefine
your reference group.
But you know, there are,
if these references groups are there
because they also provide,
so they have a function,
you want to have a large enough group
that you can do risk sharing with or so.
So there are economies of scale
to some extent in keeping these groups not
as small as it renders costless,
these particular action choice.
But analytically, I
haven't seen anything going
in that direction.
I agree, it seems a very,
very interesting question.
- [Rohini] I think, we can
take one more question.
- [Man] Thank you very much
for the fascinating presentation.
I had a question on sort of
the risks of a norm reversal,
particularly, within communities
where there's sort of an
embracing of traditional ideas.
Do we see cases where
like over generations
as re-adoption of harmful
norms, for example,
in cases where grandmothers
or mothers are uncut
or undergo sort of Sunna,
but then their children
undergo Pharaonic cases?
- So we haven't seen that
reversal in the data.
In fact, the trend is always for
in our data, mothers
maybe having Pharaonic
and daughter Sunna,
and we never see the opposite in the data.
I do think that in theory,
you could actually have that case
where there's some backlash,
again, maybe coming out of our framework.
In our framework, because of
that ranking of utilities,
by definition, if you manage
to overcome the social sanctions
and you got to apply point
where the intrinsic utility is higher,
there's no reason to move from there.
So, you would need some extraneous element
to the theory I presented,
which empirically, I think, could happen
in cases with the backlash.
But yeah, thank you.
- Thank you, Eliana, for a great talk.
And I'd invite everyone to
join us now for reception,
which I think is in the
new economics building.
So, thank you very much.
- Thank you, Rohini.
(audience applauding)
(gentle music)